the iron horse of broadcasting it's iron
you don't pronounce it iron that's what
everybody tells us the iron horse like
lou gehrig was the iron horse of
baseball
yes the word iron is iron
no no iron iron why doesn't that clock
work
why doesn't that [ __ ] work no no there's
my car
oh this clock is going somewhere normal
no i thought that's what you said i was
trying to
what iron iron iron horse
iron that's what makes
english the world's toughest language
yeah you know right sure
it is the toughest lover's language i
mean it's the easiest yeah
you were born with it because you got to
understand if english is not your first
language it is a really difficult
language to learn the most difficult
because there's so many little tiny
details
until about three weeks ago my dad
actually thought that passed out and
passed away meant the exact same thing
and nobody told me this he called me a
month ago poor
your mother passed away
then we gave her some water and she woke
up but
uh and it's cast iron it's cast iron
iron cast iron grilling grates
when you say iron uh you know what don't
be like [ __ ] larry king
that [ __ ] i say iron and he's up
my [ __ ] for [ __ ] four days
i i moved to america about a year ago
and it's been great
but i have to say that it took a long
time to learn the things
like the small subtle things like it
took me a year
to figure out that the the correct
answer to what's up
is what's up
it took a long time but now i know if if
somebody says
what's up i just say
what's up and
it feels wrong like i feel i'm not
answering a question
but they are happy so i just keep doing
it
and it took me even longer than that to
finally learn that can i help you
actually means go away
i'm always learning but like but i think
the language still has been
the most difficult part because i
studied english for years and i thought
i know english but then i moved to
america turns out
no like i didn't really know it
like all the things like i think the
hardest word
to truly master has been the word ass
ass i thought it's really easy it means
a butt
but no like like yes sometimes it can
mean a but
but that's just the tip of the asberg
like there are so many meanings to the
word ass i think it's the most
complicated word in english i've been
trying to write a whole dictionary about
just
us there's so many like for example
lazy ass
that means lazy
like like my lazy ass husband it's the
same sentence
without the ass
[Applause]
but you have to be careful because
sometimes if you add ass to something it
can actually
reverse the meaning of the original word
like for example bad ass
that's good
like bad is bad but badass it's good
but not always like dumb ass is still
dumb
so how can you know you have to know
specifically which ones are flips
and and then there's the concept of your
ass
and your ass that means like yourself
like like move your ass
that's like move everything like
move your ass and the rest of your body
and like everything if you have a car
that's included in the ass all of them
same direction just move
so your ass means yourself plus all you
have but
my ass my ass that means like no
like if i say that wow this car is
really fast and you say
oh fast my ass
so it means like no
it's not fast and
and to make it even more complicated ass
can be divided
like because if you are an ass that
means that you're being stupid
but if you're half assed
it means that you are not concentrating
properly
and if you go even smaller if you are a
piece of ass then you are beautiful
now this next thing this next thing is
about the english language
it's about little expressions we use we
we all say in the little sayings and
expressions that we use all the time
most of us
and we never really seem to examine
these expressions very carefully at all
we just sort of say these things as if
they really made sense
like legally drunk
well if it's legal what's the [ __ ]
problem
hey leave my friend alone officer he's
legally drunk
you know you can stick it why do we
always assume everyone knows where they
can stick it
suppose you don't know suppose you're a
new guy
you have absolutely no idea where to
stick it i think there ought to be a
government booklet entitled where to
stick it
now that i think of it i believe there
is a government booklet like that they
send it to you on april 15th
[Music]
undisputed heavyweight champion
well if it's undisputed what's all the
fighting about
it's the quiet ones you gotta watch
you know that one uh every time you see
a story about a serial killer on tv
what do they do they bring on the
neighbor and the neighbor says
well he was always very quiet
and someone in the room says it's the
quiet ones you gotta watch
this sounds to me like a very dangerous
assumption
i will bet you anything though while
you're watching a quiet one a noisy one
will [ __ ] kill you
suppose you're in a bar and one guy's
sitting over the side reading a book not
bothering anybody another guy standing
up at the front with a machete banging
it on the bar saying i'll kill the next
[ __ ]
comes in here who are you gonna watch
you goddamn right
lock em up and throw away the key
this is really stupid where are you
gonna throw the key right out in front
of the jail
his friends will find it how far can you
troll key 50
60 feet the most even if you lay it flat
on its side like that and you scale it
what do you get an extra 10 feet tops
this is a stupid idea
needs to be completely rethought
down the tubes you don't want a lot
people say ah the country is going down
the tubes
what poops have you seen any poops
where are these tubes and where do they
go
and how come there's more than one tube
it would seem to me one country one tube
what does every state all of a sudden
have to have its own tube now
one tube is all you need but a tube that
big
somebody would have seen it by now
somebody would have said hey joey joey
look at the [ __ ] tube
big ass [ __ ] poop over here you never
hear that you know why
no tubes we don't have tube one
we are essentially tubeless
takes the cake you know say boy he
really takes the cake
where where do you take a cake to the
movies
you know or i would take a cake down to
the bakery
to see the other cakes
and how come he takes the cake how come
he don't take the pie
pie is easier to carry in the cake easy
as pie
hey wait cake is not too hard to carry
either
piece of cake
the greatest thing since sliced bread
so this is it huh folks
a couple of hundred thousand years
the [ __ ] pyramids for christ's sakes
panama canal the great wall of china
even a lava lamp
to me is greater than sliced bread
what's so great about sliced bread
you got a knife you got a loaf of bread
slice the [ __ ] thing
and get on with your life
out walking the streets you know guy
gets a parole
they say now instead of being in prison
this guy is out walking the streets
how do we know maybe the guy's home
banging the babysitter
not everybody gets a parole is out
walking the [ __ ] streets
a lot of times they steal a car you know
and we ought to be glad thank god he
stole the car
at least he's not out walking the
streets
[Applause]
fine and dandy that's an old-fashioned
one isn't he here say to a guy how are
you he says fine and dandy
not me i never say that you know how
come
because i'm never both of those things
at the same time
sometimes i'm fine not dandy
[Music]
close to dandy approaching dandy
in the vicinity of dandyhood
not quite fully dandy other times
i am indeed highly dandy
however not fine
one time one time 1965
august for about an hour i was both fine
and dandy at the same time
but nobody asked me how i was
and i could have told him i could have
told him
i could have told him
[Applause]
i could have said to the person fine and
dandy
i consider it a lost opportunity
walking papers you know guy gets fired
he said geez poor guy well they give him
his walking papers today
did you ever get any walking papers
seriously
believe me in my life i got fired a lot
of times
you can tell never got any walking
papers
never got a pink slip either you know
what i would get
a guy would come around to my desk and
say get the [ __ ] out of here
you don't need paper for that
it's like the riot act the riot act
they keep telling you they're going to
read that to you
have you heard this thing at all
especially when you're a kid they
threaten you
the way your father comes home he's
gonna read you to riot act
tell them i already read it myself
and i didn't like it either i consider
it wordy and poorly thought out
he wants to read me something how about
the gentleman's guide to the golden age
of [ __ ]
[Applause]
more than happy i bet you say that
sometimes don't you once in a while you
say to somebody
oh i'd be more than happy to do that
how can you be more than happy
to me this sounds like a dangerous
mental condition
we had to put dave in the mental home
he was
more than happy
one more of these in your own words
people say that to you you know when you
hear that a lot in a classroom
or in a courtroom they'll say to you
tell us
in your own words do you have your own
words
hey i'm using the ones everybody else
has been using
next time they tell you to say something
in your own words say nick flat blarney
quando flew
thank you